so lots of baby boomers staying in their
homes bigger homes than they were
several generations ago
are there going to be implications
because of affordability
in terms of how many generations are
going to be living under one roof going
forward i call it the italianization of
america i mean is that something is that
a phenomenon that you've picked up on
and one that we might see increase in
time i've seen a few articles here and
there um especially in the hispanic
community for example during the
pandemic that there are now more
multi-generational
families in america than than there were
before
yeah yeah in fact you have to to
quantify and include in the analysis
because it is it has been happening in
the last couple of decades and there's
no reason to think that it'll stop
happening
when you consider that the growth of the
population is largely happening among
minority cohorts
and then you think about the baby
boomers what you hear in some cases and
some of the builders have started to
design product around this is
multi-generational living not because of
an affordability issue but because they
actually want to be close to the
grandkids where it's a way for somebody
whose age that doesn't want to be in a
nursing home can still be close to their
family and be taken care of yet still
have their own independence so lennar is
one of the ones that has been very um
forefront on this on multi-generational
housing a separate you know area
separate door entryway so some of those
things you have to take into account and
where you see it in the data
is if you exclude all the young kids
living at home and just look at all the
other adults and say well how many
adults are there in the average house
and you look at that across different
ways so you can say well let's just look
at married couples so we understand that
we've isolated both the age and the
demographic circumstance there are more
adults in those households than it used
to be
and it's slowly creeping up and what
that that essentially is on the margins
it's household destruction
and housing less housing demand and when
you peel it back even further by race
what you find is
um
blacks asians and hispanics all actually
have a higher percentage of adults per
household controlling for age
controlling for circumstance demographic
circumstance so if that's where the
growth of the population is if you have
a mix impact alone
then on top of that the affordability
question starts to come in is it are
people doubling up and tripling up
because they want to or because they
have to i think there's an element of
both and the affordability element is
one that is probably going to get more
attention as you keep rolling forward
especially after the last year and a
half where you've had so much upward
pressure on home prices and rents
well and you've also seen you know a
large withdrawal of of workers of child
care workers
um so child care is obviously more
expensive than it's been so you know
being close to that grandparent
is
possibly not even really an option
[Music]